Anfang der Woche Kanzler und
Innenministerin sind in Afrika als
Handelsreisende in Sachen Migration wir
haben verstanden dies scheint die
Botschaft bei vielen Experten aber kommt
sie auch insgesamt nicht an alle Ideen
die derzeit diskutiert werden manche die
auch in die richtige Richtung gehen
werden nicht dazu führen dass die
Erwartungen die geweckt wurden
irreguläre Migration nach Deutschland
und sülanträge zu reduzieren erreicht
werden können weil es viele blinde
Flecken gebe in der Migrationsdebatte
Scheinlösungen phantomdebatten falsche
Annahmen wie jüngst auch auf
EU-Ebene seit mehr als 10 Jahren wird in
Brüssel viel über migrationssteuerung
gesprochen aber wenig erreicht als
historischen Durchbruch deklarierten sie
die Reform im Juni Kernelement
Schnellverfahren und zwangsunterbringung
für all jene die wenig Chancen haben auf
Asyl greifen aber wird die Maßnahme
frühestens in zwei Jahren es geht um 30
Plätze allein in Deutschland werden
dieses Jahr 300.000 Asylanträge
erwartet da wird in der deutschen
Öffentlichkeit oft so getan als ob das
jetzt die Lösung sei dem ist nicht so da
wird nur eine Minderheit der
Asylsuchenden überhaupt hinkommen alle
weiteren können sich weiterhin frei in
der EU bewegen und das heißt ganz
konkret wer von Italien nach Deutschland
kommt bekommt in Deutschland weiterhin
ein zweites oder drittes Asylverfahren
wenn Deutschland es nicht schafft die
Person nach Italien zurück zu führen was
in der Praxis leider die Regel ist ein
nächster blinder Fleck dass Abschiebung
im großen Stil wie sie der Kanzler
jüngst ankündigte de facto nicht möglich
sind von den Ende Juni 280.000
ausreisepflichtigen haben 80% eine
Duldung etwa wegen Unsicherheit in ihren
Herkunftsländern oder fehlender
Ausweispapiere vier von fünf deren
Asylgesuch abgelehnt wurde dürfen also
trotzdem bleiben und zwar auch nachf
jüngstem
Gesetzentwurf dass der selbst bei den
restlichen 20% nur wenig ändern wird
sagt der Gesetzentwurf selbst es wird
angenommen dass durch die Verschärfung
der Ausreisepflicht die Anzahl der
Abschiebungen um rund
605% steigen wird großer Stil wäre das
nicht zumal nicht angesichts von derzeit
Taus illegalen einreisen pro
Tag klar ist wir brauchen die
migrationspolitische Zeitenwende die
auch kündigt wurde und die muss jetzt
wirklich mit Nachdruck und Konsequenz
umgesetzt werden und es braucht auch das
Signal nach außen dass wir
schutzberechtigten Schutz bieten aber
dass unsere Möglichkeiten begrenzt sind
und dass wir rechtsstaatlich
unterscheiden wollen wer hat einen
Anspruch bei uns einzureisen und sich
aufzuhalten und wer nicht das wollen wir
konsequenter durchsetzen blinde Flecken
gibt es zudem im deutschen Asylrecht das
aus der Geschichte lernend humanitär ist
aber auch deswegen anfällig für
Missbrauch Beispiel die weitverbreitete
identitätsverschleierung wer dies über
Jahre tut und damit seine Abschiebung
verhindert darf wenn er seine Identität
später dann doch Preis gibt häufig
dennoch legal
[Musik]
bleiben die Kollegin und Kollegen
stellen zu 95% fest bei den Personen
dass eben keine Reisedokumente vorhanden
sind keine Pässe vorhanden sind weil die
wahrscheinlich vorher weggeschmissen
oder entsorgt worden sind und das ist
das große Problem was die Bundespolizei
derzeit hat wer einmal im Land ist und
von dem wir die Identität nicht
zweifelsfrei feststellen können der wird
vermutlich über längere Zeit im Land
bleiben die eine alleslösende Maßnahme
gebe es nicht sind sich Fachleute einig
das größte Potenzial hierzu aber habe
das sogenannte Ruanda Modell
Asylsuchende würden dabei in
Drittstaaten gebracht etwa Ruanda dort
durch das UNHCR die Asylverfahren
durchgeführt das Ziel dass all jene ohne
Chance auf Asyl sich nicht mehr auf den
Weg
machen solche Drittstaaten Lösungen
wollte die Ampel laut Koalitionsvertrag
prüfen doch in Brüssel verhinderte Sie
nun eine solche Lösung de facto indem
sie zur Bedingung machte dass Betroffene
zu dem Drittstaat wie etwa Ruanda eine
Beziehung haben müssten was beim
Großteil offenkundig nicht der Fall
wäre mittlerweile habe ich das Gefühl
dass diese Regierung auf Zeit spielt ich
weiß nicht worauf sie hinaus will aber
seit Monaten wartet dieses Land auf
Lösungen die Opposition bietet die
Zusammenarbeit an und es passiert
einfach gar nichts und das ist bitter
wenn man jetzt noch in Europa ein
Stoppschild aufstellt weiß ich nicht
mehr wie die Regierung nach vorne kommen
will zuletzt gibt es einen weiteren
großen Faktor über den bislang kaum
gesprochen wurde trotz seiner Dimension
die Regelung für Kriegsflüchtlinge aus
der Ukraine mehr als eine Million kamen
etwa dreimal so viel wie es jährlich
Asylanträge aus allen anderen Ländern
zusammengibt die Aufnahmekapazität in
Kitas Schulen und Wohnungen werden
dadurch stark in Anspruch genommen
ebenso der Bundeshaushalt wegen der
direkten bürgergeldberechtigung wie
jüngst der Finanzminister
vorrechnete das Bürgergeld für die aus
der Ukraine geflüchteten schlägt im et
des Bundes im nächsten Jahr mit 5,5 bis
6 Milliarden Euro zu Buche gerade in
Zeiten knapper und Engpässen bei
Wohnungen Schul und kiterplätzen
fürchten nun noch ampelvertreter
zunehmenden Konkurrenzdruck zwischen
Migranten und Einheimischen umso
wichtiger sei jetzt eine umfassende
Strategie großes Problem in der
aktuellen politischen Debatte in
Deutschland ist das alle mit den Finger
auf die anderen zeigen die Länder sagen
der Bund soll richten der Bund verweist
auf die Europäische Union die
Europäische Union will dann am liebsten
das Tunesien oder Marokko die Arbeit
machen das ist zu einfach es gibt immer
viele schrau und an den muss man
gleichzeitig drehen nur dann wird es uns
gelingen die Situation halbwegs unter
Kontrolle zu bringen Ministerin und
Kanzler kamen von ihren Reisen ohne
konkrete Ergebnisse zurück was es für
Olaf Scholz nicht einfacher machen wird
die nun selbstgeweckten Erwartungen zu
erfüllen ja und morgen bered der Kanzler
über die Erwartungen auch mit den
Bundesländern heute ist bei uns der
kovorsitzende der Kanzlerpartei SPD Lars
klingwall schönen guten Abend Herr
klingwall schön guten Abend Olaf Scholz
hat ja kürzlich mit dem mit der Aussage
Aufmerksamkeit erregt deutschland müsse
endlich in großem Stil abschieben der
passende Gesetzentwurf das haben wir
gerade im Stück gesehen der spricht aber
nur von 5% mehr Abschiebung warum wächst
wegt der Kanzler da Erwartungen die er
eigentlich gar nicht erfüllen kann ich
finde dass die Bundesregierung gerade
sehr viel auf den Weg bringt damit
Verfahren zurückkehr zur Abschiebung
hier in Deutschland schneller laufen das
ist ja nicht nur die Frage wie viele
sind es sondern ist auch die Frage wie
schnell gibt es eine Klarheit auch für
die Betroffenen die nach Deutschland
kommt die um Asyl bitten wo dann aber
festgestellt wird sie können h nicht
bleiben und wissen sie es macht schon
ein Unterschied ob es in dem einen
Bundesland knapp vier Monate dauert bis
eine Klarheit da ist oder am anderen
sind es 36 Monate also da auch schneller
zu werden schnell Klarheit zu schaffen
die Behörden schneller zum Arbeiten zu
bekommen besser auszustatten ist etwas
was ja einz den Bürgerinnen und Bürgern
am Ende sehr klar zeigt der Staat hat
das hier im Griff und darum geht es und
das hat der Kanzler gemeint und das
bringt diese Regierung jetzt v
Formulierung war in großem Stil ab
abschieben das weckt ja doch auch große
Erwartungen und Hoffnungen warum macht
er das das Risiko ist groß dass er damit
scheitert also noch mal das muss
passieren das hat z.B auch mit der Frage
migrationsabkommen zu tun das ermöglicht
ja überhaupt erst dass viele Menschen
die in Deutschland sind die keine
bleibbe perserspektive haben dass sie
gehen können dann auch wenn es eine
Verabredung mit den Ländern gibt dafür
ist der stamp jetzt von der
Bundesregierung eingesetzt dafür ist die
bundesinnenministerin unterwegs dafür
ist der Bundeskanzler unterwegs aber was
in dem Beitrag gerade gesagt wurde ist
ja auch auch richtig es gibt nicht diese
eine Stellschraube es gibt nicht die
eine Lösung die die Frage der Migration
löst sondern es ist eine Vielzahl von
einzelnen Maßnahmen dazu gehört übrigens
auch die Integration der Menschen die
wir brauchen in den Arbeitsmarkt dazu
gehören Sprachkurse dazu gehört die
europäische Lösung alles das gehört
zusammen und alles das muss man sagen
packt diese ampelregierung an und ich
bin mir sicher das wird am Ende dazu
führen dass die Zahlen runtergehen und
nicht alle Maßnahmen die Sie gerade
genannt haben haben Auswirkungen auf die
Zahl derjenigen die bei uns bleiben oder
bei uns ankommen und zwischen müssen so
wie Sie es gerade gesagt haben und
gelingen gibt's ja auch noch einen
Unterschied aber schauen wir mal auf die
Maßnahmen z.B auf europäischer Ebene da
sprachen Scholz und
bundesinnenministerin fäer von einem
historischen Durchbruch dabei haben wir
gerade gehört bei den Schnellverfahren
geht's nur um 30.000 Fälle also Menschen
30.000 Menschen die man gegebenenfalls
schneller dann eben wieder zurück in
ihre Heimatländer bringen würde
beibehalten wird auch das Recht mehrere
Asylanträge innerhalb der EU zu stellen
und die meisten Maßnahmen treten erst in
zwei Jahren ein frühestens also
historischer Durchbruch klingt doch
eigentlich anders also man kann jetzt
die bundesinnenministerin nicht dafür
kritisieren dass ihr etwas gelingt was
davor der Union 16 Jahre lang im
Bundesinnenministerium nicht gelungen
ist nämlich eine europäische Lösung
hinzubekommen und ich will eine ganz
witig eine ganz wichtige Sache dazu tun
die sie gerade nicht angesprochen haben
mit dieser geasreform so heißt das ganze
Jahr ist verbunden endlich eine faere
Verteilung auch in Europa Hinz beekommen
endlich Länder wie Polen und Ungarn die
sich bisher ja völlig am europäischen
fig auch der Verteilung von äh
Flüchtlingen äh verweigern denen zu
sagen ihr müsst euch auch beteiligen und
wenn das nicht passiert dann könnt ihr
von der europäischen Ebene sanktioniert
werden also das ist eine ganz
maßgebliche Baustelle auch die es seit
vielen Jahren gibt zu sagen wir sind
bereit hier Menschen aufzunehmen die
hier fliehen es gibt für einige Gruppen
dann auch die Verfahren an den
Außengrenzen aber vor allem gibt es eine
europäische Verteilung und es ist nicht
Deutschland das alleine da steht sondern
alle europäischen Länder leisten den
Beitrag und das ist ein großer Erfolg
ein neues Thema was jetzt in der EU
diskutiert wird sind migrationszentren
das war lange Zeit Tabu jetzt heißt es
auch aus der SPD Fraktion heraus das ist
wünschenswert migrationszentren
außerhalb Europas zu machen zugleich hat
Deutschland aber genau das erst einmal
in Brüssel verhindert das passt auch
nicht zusammen ich finde auch dass wir
gerade gar nichts vom Tisch nehmen
sollten was realistische forchläge sind
um der Jahrhundertaufgabe Migration
gerecht zu werden das ist ja etwas was
uns die nächsten Jahre begleiten wird
wenn wir sehen wie in Afrika sich viele
Millionen Menschen noch aufmachen in
Afrika selbst aber es wird auch diese
Migration nach Europa geben und
ehrlicherweise wir brauch en ja auch die
Migration in den Arbeitsmarkt wir suchen
an ganz vielen Stellen dringend die
Fachkräfte hier und deswegen bin ich
dafür dass wir sehr pragmatisch rangehen
wir schließen mit vielen Ländern jetzt
migrationsabkommen und wenn das am Ende
dazu führt dass dann dort auch die
Asylverfahren durchgeführt werden können
dann finde ich muss man überlegen ob man
diesen Weg geht ich habe gerade Fragen
an die Praxistauglichkeit ich habe
Fragen an den rechtlichen Status auch an
das humanitäre das muss alles geregelt
werden aber ich finde wir sollten eine
solche Diskussion nicht sofort vom Tisch
nehmen